- This episode of Legal Eagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking on the link
in the description.
Authorities say that the
El Dorado forest fire
that is currently burning
out of control in California
was started at a gender reveal
party when a couple detonated
a smoke generating pyrotechnic device
to announce to the world that
their unborn baby was a son.
The device ignited the
four foot tall grass
of the El Dorado Ranch Park
on a day when most of
California was being roasted
by temperatures over a hundred degrees.
So far thousands, if not millions of acres
have burned allegedly,
as a result of this gender reveal party.
Hundreds of firefighters
are battling the blaze
and thousands of people
have had to evacuate.
So congratulations, it's a fire.
And because we live in
the dumbest timeline,
gender reveal parties
have actually sparked
at least four disasters,
including two forest fires, a plane crash
and a person killed by what
was effectively a pipe bomb.
Seriously, why do people do this?
Why do they think it's a good idea?
But this raises a
different legal question.
Shouldn't the people whose
actions start wildfires
be held responsible for the
damages to life and property?
Well, the El Dorado blaze
was just one of several fires
that continued to burn up
and down the West Coast
as extreme heat created
hazardous conditions.
And therein lies the
first of many problems
in assigning blame and recouping costs.
Here, allegedly, a couple started a fire,
but how do you decide
if they have liability?
And if so, when millions of acres burn,
where does their liability end?
And who normally pays for
damages caused by massive fires?
And finally, if billion
dollar fires are more common
because of climate change
how will the law rise
to meet this challenge?
Hey, Legal Eagles, It's
time to think like a lawyer
because we didn't start the fire,
it was always burning since
the world's been turning.
But thanks to climate change
it's burning a whole lot more often.
And in that situation
who pays for the damages
caused by these massive, massive wildfires
that are currently burning
California and Oregon?
And in general, there are
probably three main sources
that are likely to provide compensation
in a situation like
this with forest fires.
One is insurance companies,
though that's increasingly
becoming less likely
to pay for circumstances like these.
Two is the federal government.
In other words, taxpayers
are likely to pick up the bag
when insurance companies refuse to.
And then third, of
course, are other people,
people that are responsible for the fires
or people that contribute to the fires
and potentially people who
contribute to global warming.
Well fires are as old
as civilization itself.
And as a result we've developed
a number of legal tools
to help deal with the
liability that's caused
from those conflagrations.
And if you know your American history,
you might recall that Mrs
O'Leary and her cow were blamed
for the great Chicago fire of 1871,
which killed 120 people,
consumed over three square
miles of the city center
and caused $200 million in
damages in today's money.
Eventually historians concluded
that she was the victim of
anti-immigration sentiment
and the city formally
exonerated her in 1997.
But similarly, in 2017, Rita
Yeboah, a Ghanian immigrant,
was blamed for the deadly
Bronx apartment fire
that killed 13 people.
Her three year old son
was playing with the oven
when it caught fire and
Yeboah was chastised
by local authorities for
not attending to her son
and failing to close the door.
These two stories have more in common
than just anti-immigration sentiment.
There's no doubt that this
Chicago fire was started
in Mrs. O'Leary's barn just
like there was no question
that the deadly Bronx fire was started
in Yeboah's apartment,
but Mrs. O'Leary disputed the idea
that she had negligently milked a cow
which allegedly kicked over a
lantern and started the blaze.
And similarly, Yeboah fought
back by suing her landlord
for permitting dangerous conditions
in the apartment building
which may have had doors
that wouldn't stay closed.
Although both women social stigma,
neither of them had to pay
the damages to property
or the cost of fire suppression.
And that's because in America,
fires that weren't
intentionally set by arsonists
have historically been
treated as, well, accidents.
However, in 2020,
massive wildfires are
frighteningly commonplace
and they're taxing our traditional methods
of paying for them.
And we'll get to the personal liability
that stems from causing fires,
as in what happens when you
get sued for causing a fire
in just a second.
But let's start with
the more traditional way
that people get
compensation for accidents,
especially when it comes
to homes and fires,
which is the insurance industry.
And for those who are
uninsured or underinsured,
FEMA offers individual and
household disaster assistance
that can help pay for damages
to homes and businesses.
Generally, we're talking about
standard homeowners policies
the insurance policy that everyone needs
when you buy our own house.
Which generally covers
destruction and damage
caused by a fire, which
generally includes wildfires.
In the event of a fire,
the insurance company will
pay to rebuild or repair
an insured home and
remediate smoke damage.
This includes the
outbuildings on the property
such as a garage or a tool shed.
Some insurance policies
cover theft or vandalism
that happens in the event of looting
in the wake of a wildfire.
Businesses tend to have their own policies
which cover fire damage to the building,
office space and equipment and inventory.
And of course, insurance
is an important piece
of the fire cost puzzle,
but there are limits.
In this case, literally.
Because the amount of the insurance payout
is determined by the terms and
limits of the policy itself.
Generally, homeowners
policies don't cover limits
beyond one to $2 million
unless the homeowner has
paid for more coverage.
And every policy carries exclusions
that prevent the insurance
company from having a payout,
if the situation falls
under one of those scenarios
covered by the exclusion.
And whenever you have this
much property destruction
at exactly the same time,
the insurance industry is notorious
for doing whatever it
can to avoid paying out.
As one of my former law
partners used to say,
the only thing an insurance
policy is good for
is getting the right to
sue your insurance company.
Already, these wildfires
in Oregon and California
are causing huge losses
in the insurance industry.
And a few years ago, back in 2018,
the campfire fire was
the costliest wildfire
in California history,
causing more than 14,000
structures to be destroyed.
And the insurance industry had
losses of over $14 billion.
The scale of those losses,
in other words the insurance
companies had to pay out
billions of dollars to the people
that bought insurance from them,
prompted reinsurance
companies to step back.
Now re-insurance is insurance
purchased by insurance companies
that are offloading some
of the financial risks
of a major catastrophe.
The availability of re-insurance
enables better known primary carers,
such as farmers and state farm
to keep writing coverage in areas
that are most likely to
experience wildfires.
Now, while primary insurance companies
generally face tons of
regulations that prevent them
from raising prices for high risk areas,
reinsurance companies generally
are not subject to rate regulation
by the California Department of Insurance.
As a result, re-insurance
rates are skyrocketing
by as much as 70%.
So since insurers can't raise
homeowners insurance rates
because of state regulations
to match the actual price
of the things that
they're having to pay out
because of the wildfires,
generally because of state regulations,
insurance companies have
reduced the number of policies
that they underwrite.
And some people living in rural California
now have properties that
are effectively uninsurable.
So, while many homeowners
in affected areas
may be able to get an
insurance payout this year,
effectively the insurance companies
may leave the area entirely
because it's too risky.
And the housing markets
in these areas may tank
because no one's going to
buy an uninsured house,
especially in an area that's
going to be facing wildfires
year after year.
People love to dunk on insurance
companies, myself included,
but if it becomes too costly
to provide that insurance,
the insurance company will just simply
leave the market entirely.
But with insurance companies
increasingly refusing
to provide coverage for
these kinds of areas,
that might mean that
the federal government,
in other words taxpayers,
are going to have to pick up the bill.
And when it comes to the
cost of finding the fires
the federal government
has stepped in to cover
some of those costs.
The Trump administration issued
a major disaster declaration
for California wildfires,
which opened up the gates
for federal funding to be
funneled into recovery efforts.
Funding through the
declarations covers up to 75%
of the costs incurred by
California for removing debris,
conducting emergency activities,
providing transitional sheltering
and presumably raking the forest
as the president has told
us that we should be doing.
- I was with the president
of Finland and he said:
"We have a much different.
We're a forest nation."
He called it a forest nation.
And they spent a lot of
time on raking and cleaning
and doing things and they
don't have any problem.
And what it is, it's a very small problem.
We've gotta take care
of the floors, you know?
The floors of the forest, very important.
- And federal funding is also available
on a cost sharing basis
for hazard mitigation measures statewide.
Now the federal government
has spent about $1.58 billion
on fire suppression in 2019.
And this is more than triple
the amount allocated in 2018.
Unfortunately, some of the
money that was allocated
to fight fires was shifted from
fire prevention activities.
And the West coast fires
are often politicized
in a really ugly way.
Now there is a source of
quasi governmental entities
that might provide compensation
and that would be the utility companies.
Now, most experts say that
extreme weather conditions
that lead to fires are
caused by climate change.
But the laws that we have on the books
just haven't caught up with the scale
of these massive fires.
This is a big problem for
state and local governments,
which are left footing bill
for the cost of fire
suppression and cleanup.
And sometimes there's
an easy, wealthy target
for the state to go after.
For example, California's
department of forestry
and fire protection determined
that 12 devastated fires
that struck Northern California in 2017
were the result of trees coming
in contact with power lines
or other failures by the
utility company, PG&E.
And thanks to a policy known
as inverse condemnation,
the utility has to pay those damages
which the company believes
will be over $10 billion.
And even if the company is
found to be not negligent.
Inverse condemnation is a legal doctrine
that holds utility companies,
like PG&E, Pacific Gas and Electric
to a strict liability standard.
Under strict liability,
it doesn't matter if fire starts
by accident or negligence.
If it happens on the company's equipment
then the utility is
responsible for those damages.
The California court decisions
in the 1960s and seventies
allowed the state to
use inverse condemnation
to hold utilities liable.
For many years,
the utility companies
could just handle the costs
by increasing the rates
charged to consumers.
But in 2017, the California
Public Utilities Commission
turned down requests by
SDG&E for $379 million
in cost reimbursements
for the 2007 wildfires
sparked by their lines.
Now power companies may be
on the hook for actual costs
without electricity hikes.
And how they're going to
do that is anyone's guess.
PG&E filed for bankruptcy protection.
It argued that the disallowance
amounted to a violation
of the Takings Clause
of the Fifth Amendment
of the United States constitution
and the California constitution.
Legal theory is that even
though the state did not take
any PG&E property, applying
inverse condemnation
to the company effectively
transfers the company
to the state without just compensation
or any compensation at all.
And the company argued
that if it was allowed to
pass the costs to consumers
through increased utility rates,
inverse condemnation would
be costly institutional.
But a federal bankruptcy
court rejected this argument
and the case is on appeal in front of
the California Supreme court.
Which takes us to the next
it's a group of people
who are likely to face some liability.
And that is of course, the
tort liability of individuals.
A tort is a wrong committed by a person
that ends up causing harm to
someone or something else.
The tort at stake in wildfire cases
is most likely negligence.
And Black's Law Dictionary
defines negligence
as the failure to exercise
the standard of care
that a reasonably prudent
person would have exercised
in a similar situation.
And there are four elements
in a negligence claim.
Duty, a breach of that
duty, injury and causation.
The two elements that I want to highlight
in a wildfire negligence case
is the duty of care and causation,
because damages are pretty obvious here.
Now the duty of care is based
on what a reasonable person
in the same or similar
circumstance would do.
It's an objective test based
on what a reasonable person
would have done in the same
or similar circumstances.
The circumstances of the El
Dorado gender reveal party
help us to define whether a person acted
reasonably or negligently.
Did the people detonate
explosives in their backyard,
near a pool or were they in an area
with high flammable dry foliage?
What was the weather like?
Was it hot and dry or cool and rainy?
Had local authorities warned people
that conditions were dangerous
and could potentially lead to fire?
The facts determined whether
people acted reasonably
or like idiots.
I mean, acted reasonably.
And as I've said before, if
you ask a lawyer anything,
the answer is almost always, it depends.
And I try not to take
a stand on most things,
but I will go out on a limb and say that
if you are detonating a bomb
in front of a bunch of dry
grass on a hundred degree day,
that's probably negligence.
But that takes us to the
second element of negligence
that's at play here.
And that's causation.
Now, there are two types
of negligent causation,
there's actual cause and proximate cause.
And actual cause is sometimes
referred to as cause-in-fact.
It means that but for the negligent act
or the omission by the defendant,
the plaintiff would not have been harmed.
This is known as the but for test.
For example, if a couple detonates a bomb
in front of a bunch of dry grass
on an incredibly hot dry day,
and that grass catches fire
and sets their neighbor's house on fire,
then it's clear that the
but for test is made.
But for the bomb going off and
the fire consuming the house,
the house wouldn't have been damaged.
But the second type of negligent causation
is called proximate cause.
And approximate cause requires
that the natural direct
and uninterrupted consequence
of a negligent act or omission
causes the plaintiff's injury.
For example, the El
Dorado couple's actions
did start a huge fire but
where does their liability end?
What if once the fire had started,
Joe Rogan, seeing the fire spreading,
decided that he wanted
to create a copycat fire
and blame liberal activists
for setting fires?
I'm a little salty
because Joe Rogan is
blaming liberal activists
for the fires, which is insane.
- I said something on the
podcast with Douglas Murray
about people getting
arrested for lighting fires.
You know, air quote,
activists. And I got duped.
- Obviously, the El
Dorado couple's actions
are a but for cause.
Seeing the fires led Joe
Rogan to start a copycat fire.
But it's hard to say that their actions
were the proximate
cause of the second fire
spreading and causing damage.
And extending this
hypothetical even further,
what happens if the first fire
and the second fire combined
to form a super fire and
then damage other property?
Who's then responsible
for the damages caused
by the combined fire?
It's hard to say, that's the problem
of proving proximate cause.
But back to the real world,
I think a jury could be persuaded
that the El Dorado
couple acted negligently
and caused property damages.
But collecting many billions
of dollars from that couple
would be a daunting,
if not impossible task,
they're not Jeff Basos.
But just because someone
might be judgment proof
and can't afford the billions
of dollars of property damage
doesn't mean that they're
going to escape all penalties.
And there are other options
for local government.
With fires on the rise in the West,
local and state governments have started
going after people for starting fires.
In Oregon, for example,
two men were billed
for starting a fire
that burned 26,000 acres
over the course of a month.
And the men were billed
for $37 million in damages.
They both did used lawn
mowers to mow grass
during the daytime, which
was prohibited at the time
because the conditions were so hot and dry
that they could cause
a fire, which they did.
But under Oregon law, the
men could only be fined
in accordance with civil penalties.
They were each find $550 each
for a fire that cost it's a state
at least $37 million to suppress.
But California law
provides an additional way
to penalize reckless property owners.
For example, in 2016,
the U.S. Forest Service
sued a California property owner
seeking almost $25 million in compensation
for the fire that burned
15,000 acres of federal lands
in San Bernardino National Forest.
Investigators determined
that the fire ignited
in a plastic electrical junction box
that wasn't properly sealed.
An electrical discharge inside
the book box shots sparks
onto dry ground vegetation,
which sparked a mountain fire.
The theories of liability
included negligence,
trespass by fire and
violations of California's
Health and Safety Code Section 13001,
which allows the state to pass
the cost of fire suppression
to any person who
negligently sparks a fire.
Obviously the plaintiff is
unlikely to get $25 million
but the suit allows the
government to negotiate
with an insurance company,
provided the property was insured
and sends a message that
they hope will deter others
from similar conduct.
Of course, if the civil fines
and lawsuits aren't enough
a person can be prosecuted
criminally as well.
A person can be prosecuted
for reckless or extremely
negligent conduct.
The kind of thing that we would
normally call an accident.
Under California Penal Code Section 452,
it's a crime for a person
to recklessly set a fire
or burn any structure,
forest, land, or property.
California Penal Code Section 452
makes it a crime for a person
to recklessly set a fire
or to burn any structure,
forest, land or property.
A person acts recklessly
if the person is aware
that their actions could present
a substantial and unjustifiable
risk of causing a fire.
The person ignores that risk
and ignoring the risk is a gross deviation
from how a reasonable person would act
in the same situation.
A reckless action is a higher standard
than mistakes or even negligence.
Negligent acts include things,
like forgetting to turn
off the burner on a stove.
This alone won't subject someone
to a reckless burning charge.
However, acting with complete
disregard for safety may.
So for example, if you were
here or trying to heat up
a can of gasoline on the stove,
that might qualify as recklessness.
You didn't intend for a fire to start,
but you should know that if
you're heating up gasoline
on a stove on an open flame,
a fire may result from that.
And basic reckless burning
of personal property
under Penal Code Section
452 is a misdemeanor
with a maximum penalty
of six months in jail
and a fine up to a thousand dollars.
But if the reckless burning results
in a burned structure or forest land,
or if it causes great bodily injury
then the crime may be prosecuted
as either a misdemeanor or a felony.
And that's what happened to William Rupp
who served two years in
prison recklessly causing
the Lake Shasta fire in 2008.
The 56-year-old was accused
of intentionally ignoring in warnings
of a potential fire hazard
by cutting the grass
on his rural property
on an extremely dry day
when temperatures were about 106 degrees.
A mower blade struck a rock,
sparked and ignited the fire
which burned 86 rural
homes at around 1:30 p.m.
Prosecutors said Rupp
ignored warnings not to mow
from neighbors and public
service spots on TV
and told one person who
questioned him to go to hell.
And a similar situation
happened in Arizona
when an off duty border patrol agent
was ordered to pay $220,000 in restitution
after he started at 47,000 acre wildfire
at a gender reveal party.
Again with the frigging
gender reveal parties.
In that case, Dennis Dickey pleaded guilty
to the misdemeanor charge of
causing a fire without a permit
after he caused the April,
2017 sawmill fire in Arizona.
Dickey reportedly shot a
target containing tannerite,
which is an explosive substance
designed to detonate when shot
by a high velocity firearm.
And colored powder that would
reveal the baby's gender
at the party.
Tannerite has reportedly
been linked to past wildfires
and featured prominently in Tiger King.
- Are you ready for
this? (mimics gunshots)
(gunshots firing)
Oh, hell!
- Dickey of course claimed
it was a complete accident
and that he immediately
contacted authorities.
And that's probably true,
but the problem with claiming
that it's a complete accident
is that there were 40 mile an hour winds
that day in the desert in an area
that had already experienced
a drought conditions.
And you would think that a
reasonable person would know
that a high explosive in dry grass
with fast winds is likely
to cause a really big fire.
But if you're throwing
a gender reveal party
with explosives, then
you're probably an idiot
and you need to spend some time learning
how to not be an idiot.
And the best place to learn
anything is Skillshare.
And one of the best classes
is Thomas Frank's class
on real productivity, How
to Build Habits that Last.
And I'll bet one of the
keys to productivity
is not throwing a stupid
gender reveal party.
But let me ask him. Hey, Thomas?
- Stop throwing gender reveal parties.
And just a thought, maybe,
stop starting fires too.
- Yup. Thomas is a smart guy.
And his short one hour class on Skillshare
will help you stick to your habits
even after the initial
novelty period wears off.
He focuses on strengthening
your internal self discipline,
assisting that self discipline
with smart, external systems
that keep you on track and
improving those habits over time
with regular reflection.
Over 45,000 people have already taken
Thomas Frank's class on Skillshare
and not one of them has
started a forest fire.
Skillshare, as you know, is
an online learning community
that has tens of thousands
of classes on everything.
Like illustration, creative
writing, music and productivity.
The first 1000 Legal Eagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare premium
when you click on the link
in the description.
Plus after that trial ends,
Skillshare is way more affordable
than most online learning platforms
with plans starting at
less than $10 per month.
Plus clicking on that
link in the description
really helps out this channel
and it's way cheaper
than paying $37 million
for damage from a forest fire.
So just click on the link below
and get two free months of Skillshare.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Should we jail all people that
throw gender reveal parties
or just those that start forest fires?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews,
where I talk about all of the things
that are in the legal news,
from the Trump administration to COVID,
you name it, it's all here.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.